the california recall election is coming  will you vote for gavin newsom  caitlyn jenner that guy with a bear or  maybe just vote for the damn bear there  won't raise your taxes  air won't green light a poorly thought  out high-speed rail project  bear won't violate his own mandates and  eat indoors at a fancy restaurant  he's a bear he's just gonna do bare  things  the only whole bear will dig itself is  the one it sleeps in all winter long  helping conserve energy and limiting the  need for rolling blackouts  bear doesn't want to interfere in your  life there doesn't want to be near  people at all  you mind your business bearable mind is  does that sound nice for a change  maybe wear a bell or something just in  case  vote for bear i mean he's already on the  damn flag